hello everyone this is edin phong
i'm a fifth year phd student from
northwestern computer science
my research interests including online
algorithm
and macro design
i would be happy to talk about my joint
work with rap from chicago
and the title of this paper is batching
and optimal multi-stage bypass
allocations
first let's discuss some of the
motivation of this project
so we know that in lots of online
markets
so there is a central question of
request a platform to dynamically
matching the demand
or service request to the supplier or
the service providers
and in all those applications different
platform
allows different latency
for example in the google sponsor search
the google need to respond to every
search request in a very short time
period
however in the full delivery service or
the
amazon delivery service the allowance
for the latency
is much higher
and in the initial application that
allows some of the latency
platform can makes a more efficient
decision by using a batching
specifically it will grow it will
grouping the demand request together
by introducing some waiting time
and then it will make the stage-wise
matching decision
one for each of the batches
it's easy to say that this batching
strategy will give us more information
about the future
because it includes a few some of the
future in the current
decision therefore if the total number
of requests is fixed
more number of batches or another
smaller size of each batches
means that the platform can make less
informed decisions
therefore in one extreme case where
there is only a single batch
the problem the platform facing is
basically if you find the in hindsight
optimal matching
and then another extreme case where each
batch only consider
a single vertices basically this means
that the
platform are facing the matching in the
fully online fashion
and the natural question to be asked is
how about the middle ground region
and basically in this paper we try to
answer the following question
so let's fix a number of batches
how could they characterize the optimal
efficiency performance
of a matching or allocation algorithms
before introducing the model considered
newspaper
let's first revisit the classic model
for online byproduct management so in an
instance of online byproduct matching
we were given a bipolar graph where one
side of node will correspond to a supply
node
which are given offline and another side
of node
corresponding to the demand request
which will arrive
in an online fashion and the matching
algorithm
need to make an irrevocable decision
once
our demand requests arrive immediately
and there are some generalization of
this online background matching model
for example vertex weight b matching
where
each of the supply node on the offline
offline side
how he has a heterogeneous weight
and the number of online
nodes matched to your offline node which
cannot be exceed the capacity
capital b2 and we have other
electronization like online budget
allocation
where each of the supply nodes will
associate with the project
and every edge was associated with a big
eight
and there are some other variations for
example stochastic matching
free disposal stochastic reward etc
and in this talk we will mainly focus on
the vertex rate b
matching and we will consider a special
case where the capacity equals to 1.
additionally we will assume that we can
we
allow our match algorithm to produce a
fractional solution
now we can present the model considering
this paper
here we are given capital k stage and
the new batch
of the models will arrive at each stage
and for example we can have an instance
where there will be two states
and therefore we'll have two batches and
we can have another instance
where there will be four stages and
therefore there will be four batches
need to be matched
now let's define the class of
multi-stage matching algorithm
basically once a batch k arrives this
algorithm will observe
its demand vertices as well as their
indices
edges and then it will require
to make a irrevocable matching decision
which satisfy the following two
constraints
first for every demand vertices
we can match at most one unit of it
and for every supply vertices in the
current stage
the total unit we matched cannot exceed
xc 1 minus yj where yj is the current
consumption of this supply
vertices in other words the total unit
has been matched
in a period stage
and our goal is to maximize the total
weight of the matching
and we will consider competing with a
benchmark which is
optimally high size solution in other
words optimal offline
specifically we will measure the
performance
of a matching algorithm using the
notation of capacity ratio
and our goal is to identify the optimal
competency ratio
of of the of our model
and let me remind you that when capital
k equals to 1 when there is only a
single stage
this problem is a fully offline problem
and when number of stages equals to the
number of
demand vertices and every batch size
equals to 1.
this corresponds to the fully online
problem
and our formal research question is that
in the middle run regime of
capital k batches what will be the
optimal capacity ratio
now let's have a quick review what we
know from the literature
first we know that any radio location in
other words
in every stage always pick the max
weight matching
will give us a half capacity
and in fact if we're treating our batch
arrival model
as a fully online problem in other words
we will proceed
every demand vertices one by one
then we know that the balance algorithm
in the literature will give us
one minus one radiant competitive and in
the balance algorithm it will work as
follows
so for every online vertex i it will be
matched
to a supply node j which has the largest
discounted weight which is wj
times exponential penalty
associated with its current consumption
yj
and there are some other related work
including the two-stage
combinatorial optimization and other
two-stage multi-stage matching
for different model
here is our main result in this paper we
proposed a time efficient algorithm
with competitive ratio equals to 1 minus
1 minus one over k to the power of k
and we will denote this as gamma k and
we also show that there exists instance
such that no matching algorithm would
achieve a better
credit ratio against gamma k
and let me remind you that this gamma k
is between
1 minus 4 e and 1.
and for two stages the gamma gamma 2
will equal to 3
4 and for three stages it will equal to
90 over 27
and when capital k goes to infinite the
gamma k will converge to 1
small e and we can interpret this as
follow
so suppose the future batches are
pitching by the adversary
in the worst case this benefit of
batching will vanish
exponentially fast in the number of
batches
in other words if we want to gain some
efficiency improve benefit from the
batching
for a fairly large number of batches
then we will win to require that
the future batches the future notes will
satisfy some pattern which cannot be
picked by the adversary
and we also show that the same results
hold for the vertex weight be matching
budget allocation assortment if we
consider a fractional solution
and if i respect to the integral
solution we show the same results whole
for the if we have the large partial
assumption
in the remainder of this talk we will
introduce this optimal competitive
multi-stage algorithm and basically
there are two questions we need to
answer
first how to design this balanced
allocation
through a polynomial regularization
and second how to analyze this algorithm
and using a graph decomposition
and lp primal do analysis
before we formally introduce our
algorithm let's first
try to have some intuition of this model
let's first consider a very simple
example of two stage
where in the first stage we have a
complete graph
in this case it seems that which we
should try to match every
vertices on the offline side with
uniform with equal probability because
all the offline notes has an equal
weight
and in this instance this will induce a
matching
whose compelling ratio is three over
four
and how about we always match the
unknown vertices to offline vertices
with the maximum weight
well in this simple example if we're
doing so
we will give a competitive ratio of
one-half
however if we match them uniformly and
if the epsilon is
sufficiently small the capacity ratio
will converge to 3 over 4.
but should we always try to match it
fully balanced
well in this new example we will see
that if we do if we match
both sopranos with uniform probability
of the communication the component ratio
is power 2.
and if we match them proportion to their
weight
then we should get a compare ratio of
three or four
and therefore this those simple example
example suggesting that we need to start
we need to have some hedging
basically we need to add more balance to
our matching
to being robust against any arriving
graph in the future stage
basically the the next question is that
how could we formalize this
notion of balance matching for the
general graph
and how should we impose it by our
algorithm and how can we
analyze it
and here is our solution so basically we
propose
a strictly convex regularization
which pushes towards the balance
allocation
and let me remind you that this kind of
technique of
regularization has been widely used in
different areas
and now let me formally introduce what
is this real
regularization look like now suppose
that we are at the k stage
and we have the back by paragraph of uk
ekm
and the current consumption of errors
supply notes
now we want to consider the following
convex program
where the constraint is a matching
constraint and the objective function
will contain two terms the first term is
corresponding to the total wave
we get from the current stage matching
and search and the second term will be a
regular
laser terms and here the function
capital f will be some strictly convex
function
and for example we can imagine it as an
exponential function
convex polynomial negative entropy etc
in order to have a better understanding
of the convex program
with the regularization let's record the
balance algorithm in the online orphan
dimension
remember that it will continuously
allocate the arriving vertex i
to the supply node j which has a maximum
discounted weight
and it turns out that this balance
algorithm can be solved as a special
case of
our regularized max weight matching
if only one vertices arrive at the time
in other words
the batch size equals to one
and also the regularizer will be an
exponential function
and if we think of the vector of the
current consumption
as the current offline allocation levels
then
the gradient of the objective in the
convex program
will exactly equals to the discounted
weight
considered in the balance algorithm in
this sense
the balance algorithm can be solved as a
continuous
framework of the conditional gradient
percentage
now let me remind you that in a balanced
algorithm basically the same regularizer
is used at every stage
for example when there are two stages
then
in order to obtain the optimal
comparison ratio in the first stage
we should consider the quadratic
regularization
and in the second stage we should
introduce node recognization
in other words we should always try to
find the maximum weight
matching
and in a recent work it has been shown
that by doing this
we would attain the optimal capacity
ratio
when we are moving from two-stage
instance to general k-station strength
then we should consider a polynomial of
decreasing degrees
in those plots the solid line
corresponds to the small
f and let me remind you that
the regularizer capital f will be the
integral of this
small f and the dash line will
correspond to the exponential function
which i use in the balance algorithm
and let me put some to remark here
first our small f will converge
to the exponential function
and our our sequence of small f
is actually generated by a backward
recursion equation
and indeed this equation is actually a
requirement
in our primal dual proof of the company
ratio analysis
and you can check our paper for more
technical detail for this part
now it's ready for us to describe our
final algorithm
so we will first introduce those
polynomials decreasing degree
use our backward recursion equation and
then in every stages
we will solve a fractional solution
critified as a solution of the convex
programming
using the using the proper
regularizer of the polynomial
and for example in the last stage the
polynomial will have a
degree zero and therefore we are
actually
solving the max weight matching
so far we have finished introducing our
algorithm
and next we will briefly introduce how
should we
use a primo do framework to analyze the
competitive ratio of our algorithm
and briefly speaking our analysis follow
the standard framework
of the primary dual analysis and it will
work as follow
first we can write down the linear
program corresponding to the
optimal offline and then we can write
its dual program
we can consider a primal assignment for
the primal program
corresponding to the x-star so in our
algorithm
in other words in for every stage we
will solve our collapse program
next our goal is consider following due
fitting task
so basically we need to figure out a
dual assignment
which satisfies that our primals the
prime are objective in a primos
assignment
should be equal to our objective for our
dual assignment
and and also in under still assignments
the due
constraint needs to be approximately
satisfied
now the question is how should we design
such a new construction which sets
our due fitting requirement
and to do this we need to introduce a
structural decomposition lemma
first let me remind you that x k star
is a fractional solution we solve from
convex program
at stage k now let's consider a subgraph
which contain all the vertices in stage
k
in other words uk and v and we'll
consider
a subset of edges from uk
basically a h i j in e k
will be added here if their
corresponding x
k i j star is positive and now we can
consider
the kinetic component of the induced
subgraph
and we will set we will we can argue
that this will satisfy the following
property
first let's fix the arbitrary kinetic
component
and consider arbitrary two supply nodes
in within this kinetic component then we
can define
their discounted weight as the equation
in the left-hand side and we need to and
we can argue that
all the discounted weight of the supply
nodes within the same
kinetic component will be equal
and we will denote it as ckl
the second property is that there
doesn't exist edge
in ek between ukl and vtl prime
if ckl is smaller than ckl
and the last property saturation tell us
all the vertices except the vertices in
uk 0
they will be all be fully matched by our
fractional solution x k
x
and this structure and this structural
decomposition lemma
can be proved by the correct duality in
other words kkt condition
and for the unweighted version this is
equivalent to the atmospheric
decomposition
for bipartite graphs which are also
known as a matching skeleton
and this will give us all the properties
we need for new construction
and specifically we'll build our two
assignments
stage by stage initially we will
initialize
all the new variables to be zero
and in every stage we will up we will
find this structural decomposition
and update the the
due assignment corresponding to the cko
we defined on the
previous page and
in a high level this is a generalization
of a primordial framework
which has been used for online
background matching
and we generalize it to be the batch
arrival
with with multiple fixed number of
stages
and you can be sure that with this new
construction
the increment of the primal objective
and view objective
in every stage will be equals to each
other
and this is basically using a uniformity
property and saturation property
and the another lemma too which is the
main technical lemma
is to argue that the do the new
construction
will be approximately satisfied
and and it will use the monotonicity
property and uniformity property first
and then the final bond will be proved
by the induction on k
and using our recursion defined for our
polynomials
and you are welcome to check more detail
in our paper for this part
now we have finished the high level idea
of our primal dual framework
to analyze the component ratio of our
algorithm
next we will just do a quick summary
in this paper we consider multi-stage
bipartite allocation with batch arrival
we consider both fractional solution and
integral solution
with large particular assumption we
identified
a polynomial time algorithm with the
optimal capability ratio
here is some open problem left from his
paper
the main open problem is trying to
identify the optimal competitive ratio
for the integral k stage matching and
for the special case of two state
it has been solved by a recent work and
we conjecture that the optimal capacity
ratio
remains unchanged it was shifting from
fractional setting
to the integral 7.
and as we mentioned in the earlier of
this talk the benefit of batching
decrease especially fast when the number
of batches consumed goes to infinite
in other words it would be reasonable to
think about
what about k-stage matching under some
stochastic assumption
and third is there some other model
which captures
this latency and efficiency trader
this is the end of my talk if you have
any question or comments
for my talk or our paper please feel
free
to connect me through my email thanks
for your listening